well I've been in the thick of it myself
for the past month and I can assure you
this is not me being a sore loser
as you say I did stand for change UK in
the southwest but how much of the
winning brexit party's triumph was
really about brexit the 32 percent of
the electorate who voted for Nigel
Farage's company did so I contend not
because they were passionate about an
unconditional No Deal departure from the
EU but because they wanted to give
everyone a bloody nose remain as Tories
labour metropolitan elites Brussels
bankers London anyone and anything who's
been deaf to their howl of rage from
2016 the brexit party's success has
weakened the two-party lock on British
politics but not fatally arguably it
could even lead to a remain coalition
victory in the end if it causes Corbin
to commit to a second referendum the
brexit party victory was not so much a
political earthquake but a cultural
revolution comrades when I watched the
results from the EU elections I thought
I was living in some kind of parallel
universe because in my head when I
looked at the results I interpreted it
as a very clear win for the brexit Party
which was a a sign that brexit parties
had overall a majority in the referendum
then when I started watching news
channels and commentators I couldn't
believe what I was seeing I was seeing
this is a victory for a remain remain
parties if you add them all up they have
gone better if you leave the Tories out
and let it was absolutely ridiculous and
I don't know what it's going to take for
people in the establishment if I want to
call it that to understand that people
wanted Breck say in the majority and
they still do and you say was this a
reflection of brexit or was it
reflection of just wanting to give
everyone a bloody nose people voted for
the brexit party I'm sure out of
frustration but largely out of
frustration
democracy is not been followed through
and is that what people are unhappy
about and I had the pleasure of
listening to this young man this morning
and you were talking to a Tory Baroness
on the phone and it infuriated major
streets she was on the telephone
explaining that somehow it is still a
remain country or it is a remain country
people at vertex they're eccentric I'm
not comfortable in their own skin and it
is infuriating I can see that there are
two things I want to pick up there first
of all let's do the vote count the
brexit hard brexit parties if you add
together you Kipp and the brexit party
come to 34% if you roll together Lib
Dems greens change UK no I just wanted
to give the the viewers a chance to
understand that tally but you write
bricks it parties that way but what's
didn't Romi people are doing ritual it
is literally a virus moving people on
the telly okay and they're adding all
these never see much like it in my life
who's Nick brexit party is it than
really the Nigel party isn't it so but
where people actually just in your
introduction how much was it about
bricks it what don't you understand
Rachel it's called the brexit party
that's quite a clue I would suggest you
call it a company because it has a
different set up what it is is
absolutely right it represents an
absolute fury and a yearning you can now
get from one point of England to the end
of England on on Brits it council land
all the way through that is the way the
country is going and this lunatic idea
and then I will yield this for that
Michele says this is like I don't know
how much you follow football I know Greg
because this is like saying if you take
all the goals that were scored against
Manchester City that didn't win the
bloody premierships
you ain't lost okay I think what will
happen now is we will have a second
referee I think there will be a second
referendum and I think the main will win
no no I'm not saying because we can't
you're now seeing people who in
Parliament who are saying there's no we
can't decide this the only way they do
they decide this just put it back to the
people so we all never have an election
or we have a referendum I don't think
any of them particularly I don't think
either labor or Tory's gonna go for I
don't think that's right actually what I
feel is the most important point in
which was that the people who voted
brexit still want
brexit to happen but without giving any
instruction I said what sort of bricks
that they want is it No Deal do they
really want No Deal that's what you have
to this is a kind of very sw1 London
conversation most people who voted
breakfast don't really care very much
they basically want to leave the
European Union and they want things to
be as economically as little different
as possible consistent with being
outside the political well you say it's
not available but let's let's remember
all the things that are happening now if
we'd had this conversation a year ago
everybody was being Donna it's nonsense
actually what I think is probably going
to happen is something completely
different to this and forgive me Rachel
the Joker in the pack here is your
brother who I can't tell you how much
it's like chewing ground glass for me to
say this I think he may emerge as both
Victor yeah Tory party leader leadership
and also because of his capacity here to
have a media about everything he
promised he may turn out to be the guy
who says you know what I'm gonna get a
deal it doesn't look anything like what
I've been promising for the last three
years but you're gonna buy it from me
and actually can I just say I think
you're right in the sense I mean I hate
that idea I think that my party not my
candidate but that's if you were looking
at it objectively that's where we may
end up and which politician has treasom
a predicted what politicians on the UK
landscape is capable of eating his own
words
swilling it down with a glass of
champagne and having everybody cheering
I want you to your mouth Trevor Johnson
yes what makes you think that there's in
any way the end to the two-party system
this isn't a [ __ ] I've been hearing that
it's the end of the two-party system for
the last goodness knows how many well
when the general election comes out
everybody goes tribal again no well
you're right to say that though you kept
one the last European parliamentary
elections and then in the following
general election the two-party system
took 80 percent of the votes so yes but
doesn't mean it's gonna happen again
that's because they got was it four
million votes or something but because
we've got first-past-the-post they ended
up with one seat so if you just have a
quick I've got a statistic about who
would stick with the brexit party and
who wouldn't so if you look at this for
example 1/2 of labor versus who switch
to the brexit party have said so that
they will stay there in the next general
election and it goes on that two-thirds
of Tory voters who switch they're said
that there will stay so I'm not sure
that it's going to be as simple as
people just having a process / and then
reverting I think what will happen
I would like Nigel Rodgers party to
drive through some form of proportional
representation do that I mean I wonder
what - a proportional representation
I think the present system in this
candidate first-past-the-post doesn't
make any sense
but the people who have got controlled
both the Tories and labour they're never
gonna pop Cofer they're not in a usual
political climate something's got to
change and their themselves must
complete the thing that the thing that
matters most to most of them is keeping
their seat they're gonna keep their seat
by continuing the count system just to
another Inglot tourists at the elections
what was for you Rachel what was the
high point of your campaigning what was
the low point everything was a high
point politician I'm going to remain as
hammering core messages ok doesn't it as
Hugh they're risking wrote in The Times
brilliantly change UK managed to pick a
fight in an empty bar and lose to the
furniture which i think is a brilliant
life well indeed and this was a
brilliant moment from one of your change
UK colleagues
can you can you just look at your hands
please you're really good you're doing
whatever sir that's the best I've seen
it done brilliant that's it it's there
that's the answer to this it's in your
hands
Rachel can we just find out where you're
going next party do you want me to
destroy you know the trees the brexit
astonished that you know how to hammer
home the key message isn't it change UK
I have no idea what the key mess is out
look at your hands
time for a change in the law is the
pledge